hello everyone
nowadays data is the new fuel and
software developers
are the ones driving the world with it
according to the recent survey
the employment of software developers is
projected to grow
21 from 2020 to the year
2028 much faster
than the average of all the occupations
and the employment of
systems developers is projected to grow
10 percent
the one reason for which most of the
youngsters and even experienced
employees
are turning their heads towards the i.t
industry but still
there is one question in everyone's mind
how do i become a software developer
well
that's exactly what we are going to
discuss today in this session from
simply learn
now let's quickly begin with our session
first we will have a briefing on the
agenda
we will start by learning the biggest
tech giants that are in a constant hunt
for software developers followed by that
we will have a quick look at the base
scales for a software developer
based on the experience level starting
from the typical
entry level to an experienced level
software developer
both in india and the united states of
america
up next we will slowly enter into our
core topic
where we will have a quick recap of what
exactly
is software development and who do we
call
a software developer once we have a good
understanding of that
we will dig into our main topic that is
the types of software developers
where we will discuss the different
types of software developers
and the key languages frameworks that
you need to have
to become one so just to make things
better
we will also discuss some of the
additional
skills that you may require to be ready
in real time
so this finishes our agenda hope i made
myself clear with it
now let's get started
now first up we have the major tech
joints that hire software developers
companies like microsoft cognizant
amazon emphasis google oracle
accenture ibm capgemini
facebook evi wipro hp
you name it regard it every major mnc
that is relying on software
and iit is always in a constant hunt for
the best software developers
as they are the ones which keep them
running i can bet the id industry can
barely go down
after undergoing all these advancements
and countermeasures
against any unexpected natural or
unnatural calamities so you can be
assured that you can bag yourself
a decent and stable job in the current
it
also all these companies are ready to
pay
a hefty and handsome salary for their
employees
our next point of discussion is all
about the salaries of software
developers
first let's begin by considering india
and check the salaries
paid to software developers salary paid
to an entry level software developer
ranges from 3 lakh rupees to
16 lakh rupees per annum on the other
hand
for an experienced level software
developer
the salary in india ranges from 6 lakhs
to 22 lakhs
per annum as their average salary
now coming into the united states of
america
the salaries for an entry-level software
developer
ranges from 53 000 to
105 000 per annum
similarly on the other hand for an
experienced level
software developer america pays
70 000 to 150
000 per annum now
in the next stage we will learn about
the term software
development so we can define the term
software development as follows
software development is a branch of
computer science which includes the
development
and building of computer systems
software and
application software now that we know
the process of software development
let's move further and learn more about
a software developer
so who exactly is a software developer
so a software developer can be defined
as follows
software developers are computer science
professionals
who use the knowledge of engineering
principles and programming languages to
build a software
now that we have some briefing about
what exactly is
software development and whom do we call
a software developer
we will now enter into our code topic
for today's discussion
where we will learn the types of
software developers
and the languages including the
frameworks that you need to know
to become one and also to make things
better
we will also learn some of the
additional skills that you might need
just in case to make sure you never miss
anything in real time
so let's get started we will begin
with the front-end developers so
basically the front-end developer
specializes in the programming of
visual interfaces including its
aesthetics and layouts
the frontend developers code runs on the
web browser
on the computer or a mobile user of the
site
it is very high level work normally far
removed from the hardware
it requires an understanding of human
and
machine interaction and design
principles
more than a computer science theory
so the popular languages required to
become a front-end developer
are html css and javascript
followed by that the major frameworks or
the ides that you might have to master
to become a front-end developer are
visual studio
intellij by chan also some of the major
additional skills that you might require
are
get version control for example
if something goes wrong along the way
the last thing you'll want to do
is start over from the beginning version
control is the process of tracking and
controlling changes to your code
so that this won't happen so version
control software
is a tool you will use to track those
changes so you can go back
to the previous version of your work and
find out
what went wrong without tearing the
whole thing apart
followed by that the next additional
skill you might need is
to build responsive design that controls
and supports
multiple devices these days we use
any number of computers phones and
tablets
to look at web pages ever notice how
these pages adjust themselves to the
devices you are using
without you doing anything on your end
this is due to the responsive design
understanding responsive design
principles and how to implement them
on the coding site is the key to the
front end development
so the last and important additional
skill is to be able to write code for
various types of testing
bugs are the reality of the development
process
in order to keep things moving you will
need to test your code for
bugs along the way so the ability to
test and debug makes the list of
essential skills for front-end
developers
there are a couple of different testing
methods for web development
out of which functional testing looks
like a particular piece of functionality
on your site
like form or a database and make sure
it does everything you've coded to it to
do
followed by that we have unit testing
unit testing is another method
it tests the smallest bit of your code
that's responsible for one thing
on your site and examines it
individually
for correct operation so followed by the
frontend developers we have the back-end
developers
so the back-end developer is the one who
specializes in design
implementation functional call logic
performance and scalability of a piece
of software
or system running on machines that are
remote from the end user
backing systems can grow to very complex
but their complexity is often not
visible
to the users for example consider
google search engine the front end part
is very simple user interface
with a title and a text box and two or
three buttons
the packing is enormously complex system
able to crawl the web index and find
what you're looking for with a growing
area of sophisticated mechanisms
so with this we will move ahead and
understand
the major programming languages and
frameworks
that you need to specialize to become a
back-end developer
so the major programming languages that
you might be needing to become a
back-end developer are
scalar programming language java pearl
and finally the python programming
language
these are the leading and cutting-edge
programming languages preferred by
professionals
in real time to code the back-end
process
also the major ides or the frameworks
that you might be needing
to become a backend developer are the
visual studio
intellij and python so the important
additional skills that you might require
to become a backend developer are
having some good knowledge of session
management in a
distributed environment basic exposure
to the front-end technologies like html
and css is desirable followed by that
you should be having an awareness of
security concerns
which is important because different
layers may have
different kinds of vulnerabilities
followed by that
the back-end developers must be able to
code
unit testing and other types of
functional testing
for the backend part followed by this we
will move ahead into the next type of
developer
which is the full stack developer
the full stack developer is the one who
does both
the front end and the back end he or she
has the skills required to create a
fully functional
web application also we will discuss
some additional features to become a
full stack developer
the first one is knowledge of both front
end
and the backing fundamentals as we made
it clear that
a full stack developer is concerned with
front end
and the back end they must be possessing
the fundamental design skills
followed by that the next important
skill is
knowledge of database which is crucial
all the web applications need a database
where all the data will be stored
this is to ensure that developers can
access the data later
database stores calls for an experienced
and
skilled full stack developer who knows
relational databases
and database storage inside out finally
back in programming languages like ruby
and php
while we have covered the two most
critical front-end languages that is the
html and css along with javascript
the other important part of software is
the back-end
while the back-end development is a
whole new different game
there's plenty of programming languages
to choose so
out of which the major programming
languages that i would like to mention
are ruby php python
java followed by the full stack
developer we have the mobile developers
so the mobile developer is the one who
codes the applications that run on
mobile devices such as smartphones and
tablets
mobile development was almost unheard
before the early 2000s and
the explosion of smartphone market
before then
mobile development was considered as a
subset of embedded
development so the major programming
languages that you might want to
consider
to become a mobile developer are
bison kotlin javascript and
java so majorly java and kotlin are used
for
android development so the ides and
frameworks that you might want to learn
to become
a mobile developer are visual studio
android studio app code and webstrom
followed by that we will also discuss
some of the additional skills that you
might require to become
a mobile developer you should have
the ability to learn quickly and you
should also possess the ability to
interpret and follow the technical plans
followed by that you should be having
the major skill that is the
instantaneous
problem solving skill and finally strong
communication skill to understand your
client requirement
followed by the mobile developer we will
enter into
the desktop developer so the desktop
developer is the one who works on
software applications
that run on desktop operating systems
such as
mac os windows and linux back in the 80s
these were one of the most common types
of developers
popularized by inexpensive development
environments such as
turbo pascal turbo c visual basic
qxc visual studio and delofey so to
become one of the desktop developers
you might want to learn the following
programming languages and
programming ides or frameworks
so the programming languages that you
might want to learn are python perl
javascript java also the major ides that
you might want to learn
are visual studio intellij
pycharm and netbeans
followed by that the additional skills
that you might require
are you should be able to build
reusable code and reusable libraries
code optimization for maximum speed and
scalability of desktop applications and
to use automated testing platforms and
write unit tests and finally to be able
to test
debug and document any custom codes that
you might want to add to your desktop
application moving ahead we shall enter
into the next type of developers which
are
the web developers so the web developers
are the software developers
who specialize in creating websites they
either the front-end developers or the
back-end developers
or sometimes even the complete full
stack developer
web development became a very common way
to enter the software engineering world
in the late 90s and early 2000s so the
major programming languages that you
might want to
learn to become a web developer are
python
css javascript and php
also the major frameworks or the ides
that you might require to become
a web developer are visual studio
intellij dreamweaver and the pycharm
so some of the major additional skills
that you might require to become a web
developer
are to understand the standard lawsuits
on web design copyrights
you might think that this is not a
necessary skill for you and
there is a legal department which will
be taking care of this
but knowing a basic up-to-date copyright
laws is something you should keep in
mind
especially when you are part of a large
development project
where your team is given a lot of
creative control
likewise if you are a coding
entrepreneur trying to build the next
facebook or twitter
knowing copyright and cyber loss
regarding privacy
could either mean a success to you or a
devastating lawsuit over your head
so it's better you know some basic
lawsuits
own web design copyrights followed by
that you should be having
some strong basics of html and followed
by that you should be well versed with
version control systems and finally you
should have some decent knowledge of
debugging tools so with this we enter
into our next type of developer
which is the graphics developer
so the graphics developer is specialized
in writing software
for rendering lighting shadowing shading
curling and management of scenes
these developers are often responsible
for integrating technologies
in gaming and video production industry
graphic development used to be a form of
low-level development
requiring advanced math and computer
science training
it is becoming more accessible with the
introduction of commercial
and open source frameworks for example
very few people today are able to write
a shader from
scratch so the basic programming
languages and
the programming ides or frameworks that
you might require to become
a graphics developer are c plus plus and
c and similarly the ides that you might
require are
opengl webgl directx
and unity so some of the additional
skills that you might require to become
a graphics developer
are understanding the client requirement
as it is a key to create a successful
project
followed by that creativity is one of if
not the most important skill
for a graphics designer and finally
having a sound knowledge of html and
fundamentals of programming languages
such as c
plus plus and c will be an added weight
on your resume
next ahead we have the data scientist
so a data scientist is a special type of
developer
who writes software programs to analyze
data sets
they are often in charge of statistical
analysis
machine learning data visualization and
predictive
modeling so the important programming
languages that you might want to learn
to become a data scientist are
our programming language mysql python
and even sometimes
java so the important frameworks or ids
that you might require to become a data
scientist
are jupiter notebook spyder
pycharm and rstudio so some of the
additional skills that you might require
to become a data scientist
are these knowledge of data edl tools
there is
data extraction data transformation and
data loading
a data scientist has multiple data
sources such as
mysql mongodb google analytics and many
more
so data scientists have to extract data
from such
sources and then transform it for
storing it in a proper format
or structure for the purposes of
querying an analysis
so having a fundamental knowledge of edl
tools is always
important so followed by that the next
important skill is the data
visualization tools like
tableau and power bi results that cannot
express
are considered ineffective hence
using some top-notch data visualization
tools like tableau
and power bi is really important for a
data scientist
followed by that we have communication
skills so communication skills are
really important to understand your
client requirement
and help him with the right data which
he needs
so finally the big data frameworks most
of the organizations are using big data
analytics to gain hidden business
insights
it is therefore a must-have skill for
data scientists
so with this we will move ahead into the
next type of developer
which is the big data developer
so what exactly is a big data developer
so
big data developer is the one who writes
software programs to store and retrieve
vast amounts of data and systems such as
data warehouses
relational databases data lake
management systems etc
using the most crucial tools which are
the extract
transform and load so
some of the major programming languages
and the frameworks that you might
require to become a big data developer
are scalar programming language
our programming language java most
importantly and next is the python
so the major frameworks that you might
require to become a big data developer
are
joby the notebook spider pycharm
and apache spark so apache spark
is a processing layer similar to
mapreduce
so this is the fastest processing layer
compared to mapreduce so i prefer you to
learn the basic terminologies and the
components of
hadoop along with apache spark
processing layer
so followed by this we shall also learn
some additional skills required to
become a big data developer
so the additional skills include to be
capable enough to design
build install configure and support the
hadoop system
working on desperate data sets create
scalable and
high-performance web services for
tracking data maintain security and data
privacy
so for hadoop we have kerberos for
security and data privacy
and finally high speed querying so high
speed querying can be done by framework
such as
hive edge base etc so finally
we will enter into the last type of
developer in today's session
which is the cyber security developer
so who exactly is a cyber security
developer
so the cyber security developer
specializes in creating systems methods
and procedures
to test the security of software system
and exploit and fix the security flaws
so this type of developer often works as
a white hat
ethical hacker and attempts to penetrate
systems to discover
their vulnerabilities so the major
programming languages and frameworks
that a cyber security developer must
know are python javascript and php
also the important frameworks that the
cyber security developer must
know are information security management
systems
cis controls and nist csf
adding on to that the important
additional skills that a cyber security
developer must
know are the fundamentals of hacking to
be a cyber security developer you need
to think like a hacker to fully
understand
how a system could be breached and in
turn creative effective solutions
to stop these attacks from penetrating
into your system
followed by that the next important
skill is to have a fundamental knowledge
of computer forensics
so what if your efforts fail and your
confidential data gets recovered
even after you destroy every single clue
of it
while computer forensics and cyber
security are two separate fields
they actually are closely related so
having a foundation on
computer forensics can help you excel
your cyber security career
followed by that the next important
skill is to pay attention to
every single detail so being confident
is good
but being ready is not a crime being a
cyber security developer
you will be responsible for continuous
network monitoring and
will need to be able to quickly identify
concerns and
come up with real-time security
solutions to address them
so why do you give some attention to
every single detail
and be ready for the next potential
threat
so the last additional skill is
fundamentals of cross-platform security
cyber security isn't just limited to
computers you'll need to be comfortable
working on variety of operating systems
computer systems mobile devices cloud
networks and
wireless networks and to keep up to date
on advances in the field of all of them
so with this we have come to an end of
this session on how to become a software
developer if you have any queries
regarding this session or
should you think that we missed out any
specific type of developer
or if you have any suggestions for us
then please feel free to drop them down
in the comment section below
so this is ravi signing off and thank
you
until next time
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here